hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 18 of my road to one bill series
today we're going to be finishing up
Larn diplomacy and you know how I know
that is because I record this afterwards
and I've already done it uh but that
aside we do have to finish up a couple
more skill requirements we need to get
our wood cutting to 55 and our crafting
to 61 on top of that we do have about
three more quests to do and they're all
pretty long uh so yeah let's get started
all right so if you remember in the last
episode uh we did get our crafting level
up high enough to start making the
unpowered orbs of the molten glass um
this is by far the most coste effective
way to get your crafting level up at
about 54 I can start making water battle
stabs but uh it's pretty expensive
honestly and I think it might just be
better to take a bit longer uh but save
about 2 mil or something and I don't
think I can make 2 mil in an hour very
easily so I think it's better to just
potentially just smelt unpowered orbs
all the way to 61 but we'll go to 54 for
now and then see if we change your mind
all right there's level 50 crafting uh
really didn't take too long we're
getting about uh 80k XP an hour doing
this uh so pretty good and it's only
costing us about 100 200k an hour to do
it as opposed to 2 mil so definitely
much more cost effective all right so
we're just about to hit 504 crafting and
we could start crafting the water battle
stabs uh but I looked it up and it's
going to cost about 2 to 2.5 5 mil just
to get those uh well I guess six seven
levels and uh it'll only take an extra
hour by doing it with the unpowered orb
so for an hour worth of saving as it's
going to cost an extra 2 mil so
definitely not worth it all right so
that being said uh we're just going to
go ahead and buy some more molten glass
we need about 2900 uh which will take
about 2 hours uh to smelt it all or blow
it all whatever you want to call it uh
but again it's going to save us quite a
bit of money so it's definitely going to
be worth it you can see we would have
lost almost 2.5 mil in total and about
1.6k on each battle St so definitely not
worth it uh so some of you may have seen
my farming guide I released the other
day um but I in it I showed that you can
make uh quite a bit of money by turning
seeds into saplings uh which it's really
easy to do only takes 10 minutes or
something and you can do it right at the
Grand exchange pretty well uh so we're
going to go ahead and buy some papaya
tree seeds because they have a 1.5k
margin on them uh which is pretty decent
uh 200 SE will give us about 300 G
profit and most of that time is spent
waiting for the items to buy and sell uh
so it's a good thing to do while I'm
turning up my crafting uh which I still
have to do uh but we want to kind of mix
it up or I'm going to get a little bored
so on top of the papaya seed I think
we're going to do the Maple seed as well
uh which looks like it has about a 3K
margin on it which is really good uh
that would net us about 600k which would
be awesome uh they're going to buy a bit
slower than the papayas tree seeds uh
but still definitely worth the money and
we'll find maybe one more seed cuz we
have about 8 mil left so we're just
looking up the willow seeds on GE
tracker uh looks like there's actually
quite a few that trade every day 10K for
both the seed and the sapling uh which
is pretty decent and uh the margin on it
seems to be almost 2K as that' be about
400k in profit and especially for an
item that buys this quickly definitely
going to do that and yeah that's
probably good for now uh we'll need some
potted soil as well and some water and
cans uh but we'll get back to crafting
all right there is level 57 crafting uh
now we can make green dragon Hy van
braces not a huge milestone uh but we're
back to the crafting grind and we will
shoot for 61 all right we bought all the
papay tree seeds uh really quick only
took about 10 minutes I did not get many
crafting levels in unfortunately um but
at the same time it'll be nice to get
some more money uh so what we need is a
bunch of potted or filled potted plants
and uh I'm an idiot and you need the
gardening trial as well for the if you
didn't watch my video at all it's really
easy uh just get that [__] gardening
TR there we go and then just use them on
the plants and that's going to make a un
potted uh papaya tree and then you just
have to water it now this would also be
really handy if I had the lunar
Spellbook uh which is what I'm working
towards so to be fair I am working on it
but um you could also just humidify the
pots I think or maybe just the watering
cans either way uh it would save a bit
of time but we're just watering all the
plants and uh should only take a few
minutes all right we have 198 eight
papaya saplings in our inventory uh
we're going to go recheck the price
quickly and it looks like they are
selling for uh 10.5
mil I wish
10.5k and uh we'll pop them in here to
sell for
10585 uh giving us a sell price of 2.1
mil and uh we bought them for 1.8 so
about 300K so pretty good especially
since that was only 10 minutes of work
pretty well on top of that we do have
198 Willow seeds all bought and we'll go
ahead and pot those as well all right
we've got them in pots and then we're
just watering them again uh really
excited to get the humidify spell
because doing this is kind of a pain in
the ass with the watering cans uh but
either way it's not that much work all
right we have 198 uh Willow saplings and
uh we did actually sell the papaya
saplings pretty quickly already as you
can see that's about 300 can profit uh
now for the willow seeds we bought them
for 1.7 mil and we're going to pop them
in here to sell and we just recheck the
margin look like they sell for about
10.2k uh so pretty close to what we
bought them for before and if you recall
uh we bought them all for 1.7 mil sell
selling them for two uh which is another
300 can profit with very little work
there we go there is 60 crafting we just
need one more level then we finally have
all the skill requirements for uh lunar
diplomacy and that will be nice although
we do have uh two long quests to do
before we can actually do the quest all
right pvm Leb coming in with 160 blue
feathers 160k sorry uh very good job man
uh surprised all of you are able to get
all these feathers and aren't just
competing for the price but oh maybe you
are I don't know oh my God on3 R38
coming in with
243k feathers you are definitely in the
lead I think you've given me almost half
of the feathers possibly uh so thanks a
lot man appreciate it all right and we
have uh all the maple seeds did buy we
had to jack up the price by about an
extra K uh but still leaves us with
about a 2K margin on each seed uh which
is not as cost efficient but still very
easy money definitely going to go ahead
and add these to the potted plants all
right uh we ended up potting all the
maple saplings uh which didn't take too
long uh looks like we can sell them for
42.7k um so we'll have to calculate the
profit afterwards cuz we did buy the
seeds in two different chunks but we're
selling them off for about 8.5 mil and
we'll see how much we bought them for in
a little bit all right so if we take off
the cost of both these SE s it leaves us
with about 430k in profit which is
really good uh again only 10 minutes of
work all right guys there is 61 crafting
all the skill requirements are done
there's no more hiding we have to go do
the quest so the first Quest that I have
been putting off for a long time is
femic uh trials so I'm glad I'm finally
able to or motivated at least to finish
this Quest cuz it looking so stupid with
that Snak skin bandan uh but anyway we
do need to finish this Quest it is kind
of a long one and we need seven votes
and it takes probably an hour or two and
uh but yeah we're gonna do it and let's
get started with it okay we actually got
76 range uh we have to kill this lanzig
guy uh but if we don't get the drop from
him pretty quickly we're going to go
ahead and do the other option uh but
we'll try another little bit longer all
right we' have gotten the uh loot or the
liar or whatever it is we're just doing
a a sick little song and yeah there we
go uh only uh three more dudes I have to
convince I think all right we're on to
that point of the quest where you have
to go uh kind of it's like one small
favor you have to go to the merchant and
go to all these people uh no one
actually has what you need so you have
to go to the next person and then uh you
just end up getting pissed off and it's
one of those parts where the quest guide
looks like it's going to be quick uh but
it's definitely not yeah but that's okay
we'll go ahead and finish this up oh my
God this kid is extorted me for 5,000
gold for freaking
note oh that's unfortunate all right
guys there we go that should be from
trials completed uh we got 2.8k in like
10 different skills or something uh
let's see what we end up leveling
up all right our fishing level is up to
37 that's it that's kind of
disappointing but anyway we can finally
wear the Archer Helm which is nice all
right guys The Last Quest prerequisite
is uh Shadow Village which is another
pretty long Quest and unfortunately it
doesn't have any really useful rewards
at least for us now uh but we have to do
it or we can't even start lunar
diplomacy uh so we're starting it off
and uh well come back in like 2 hours
when we're done all right uh we're
finishing up the boss which is I
understand that they may not have
intended for everything to be safe
spotted but damn this is extremely easy
Oh no just run onto the other side of
this conveniently placed
Rock and don't take any damage Perfect
all right there we go guys we just
finished up the quest uh 3.8k crafting
experience access to sh shilow Village
which will be useful eventually but
right now it's pretty much pointless but
that is it we can now start lunar
diplomacy all the requirements are done
and I'm excited to get started all right
guys we have started lunar diplomacy uh
run the first part uh which is actually
getting to the island because apparently
the boat has been cursed uh so we're
kind of stuck at this Pirates Cove area
for now uh kind of interesting place
never knew about it uh they have Moss
Giants on it which I don't know might be
useful at some point all right we're
just removing the curse from the boat
apparently there are five symbols on the
boat that are somehow preventing us from
getting to the island uh cuz we tried to
go do the big loop-de-loop which was
kind of funny uh we should have just a
couple more of the symbols to remove and
then we should be good to go all right
there we go we're on uh the moonclan
island and now we got this sick cut
scene greeting us okay it was cool now
it's just kind of standing here but uh
yeah it's another one of runescape's um
classic cutcenes
and Bam a so
smooth and there we go we're on the
island so now we can actually continue
with the quest all right guys we have
finally got into the dream world uh this
is the last part of the quest that we
have to do and then we can finally have
access to the lunar spell book uh which
be working towards for quite a while so
let's get this done with so the first
challenge is a dice challenge we have to
get all the dices to add up to the
number he shouts out pretty easy but uh
still would be kind of challenging if I
didn't have the guide I guess okay this
kind of sucks there is no pre-written uh
strategy for this one you just have to
do do it over and over again until you
finally memorize the path uh we're about
half way through uh so maybe we can just
clutch it for you guys right
now okay that was good and forward you
never know if they're going to make it
super obvious I mean knowing Jag a they
might make it like a total straight line
just to [__] with
me uh yeah let's go straight one
more uh [__] all right we finished all
the challenges we're on to the final
boss which is uh me or you uh I don't
know why the bosses are so easy in this
game literally have just one more damage
to do
and boom all right guys there we go
lunar diplomacy is complete that has 5K
magic experience and 5K Rune crafting uh
which actually gets a run crafting to 28
which is kind of nice and uh now we can
do dream Mentor if we want but I'm
really happy to have the lunar spell
book and uh
finally all right guys I think that's
what we're going to wrap it up for today
we're just going to do a quick recap of
what we got done today uh so as far as
our cash stack we will take out uh the
rest of stuff that is selling in rge uh
we have another maybe I 500k in there
still selling off uh but mainly of
course the progress that was completed
was involving uh lunar diplomacy so we
finally got uh that Quest done we now
have access to the lunar spell buck as
you can see here on top of that we got
our blue feather cach up to
760k and our um coins are up to 17.8 mil
probably closer to 18 mil our skills are
up to 61 crafting 55 wood cutting and we
did get a ranging level as well so
pretty stoked to finally have lunar
diplomacy done we're going to use a home
teleport there we go and uh going to
going to take a while to get used to not
having access to regular teleport uh but
yeah I hope you guys enjoyed the episode
and I will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
oh